what a blog I like the camera angle here
abandoned this this meeting I had with
an incredible couple around there dog
training business lights out really
valuable for a lot of you check it check
it out and pass this one on because
front ton of your real friends what's
been the biggest change when when you
guys kind of came across my stuff I
don't want to give too much information
out because every single dog network but
I've seen results I see you you thought
it was a secret sauce but it works the
reverse reverse after listening to you
and Mikey give everything and people
still he's giving you everything you
need people still want to work with you
with their unique business sure cuz
there's always that's right as much as
you learn there's still the nuances of
the details plus just the fact that
sometimes people just want to pay back
some thirty that's done right by them
like if we designed thousand dollar
website and logos you would much rather
hire vaynermedia to do that for you than
somebody you might have used in San
Diego yeah so works yeah so that's been
the biggest thing for me for sure I've
seen from you after listening area is
patience I like zero patience so right
before we start listening to you I
actually reached out to Daniel Bernstein
gym guys I she has a blog B where what
was on Forbes 30 under 30 because she
was looking for a dog trainer hmm so
that's a story yeah so I reached out to
her and she flew me out here mainly
because she's like I interviewed all
these other dog trainers nobody was
normal so she's like this girl looks
normal I'm gonna fly her out so after
working with her I would say so I took a
week off worked with her stayed with her
helped her introduce her puppy to her
other dog and just have that transition
smoothly after that for about a month
and a half the business declined because
I took a week off and this is right
before we started listening to you and
so Michael of course is like oh my gosh
this wasn't my pathetic cuz it's gonna
be huge
right and then once he started to listen
to you he's like patience patience it's
not about the present like don't be
looking at the present when we stop
focusing on like every single day oh my
god we're not selling like a package you
know this person didn't convert when we
just looked at the bigger picture like
the content that just keep doing trust
in the process its brand versus sales
it's just so big it's so big it's it's
um I'm just you know people struggle and
I'm apathetic like I'm competitive I
didn't come for you know I didn't always
have like you know people were like oh
it's easy when you have it it's it's not
bad it's it's that it just doesn't make
any sense to look at your life in a six
week period when your life is much
longer than six weeks to me the bigger
the biggest disconnect is people's you
know I always say your ambition versus
your actions if you want to build
something like you guys aren't working
for Bank of America or vaynermedia or
you know like McDonald's like you're
working for yourselves and when you want
to do that
like it doesn't make sense not to be
paid you want something so big I don't
think everybody understands how big it
is to be able to live life on your own
yeah and your control and how you do it
and so if you're asking the universe for
such a thing of course it should be
worse and harder and longer and grinder
and difficult of course yeah you know
yeah it's that's the thing that I need
to find a better way to articulate which
is do you actually understand what
you're asking for do you understand that
you're asking to live a top 1% life in a
7 point 7 billion person world if you
then wrap your head around what you're
actually aspiring to do well then all of
a sudden all the [ __ ] that comes
along with it makes a hell of a lot more
sense everybody just thinks they're
entitled to it yeah yeah the amount of
like like I lose on a daily basis every
day every day I'm losing on the daily
basis you know but I think I'm winning
on the decade basis you know yeah it's
cool makes me happy huh you've been here
all day yeah anything interesting
say hello to anybody all the fun yeah
and you've spent good I mean obviously
came out here like you guys spend time
in New Yorker yeah I trained some dogs
New York so there's a lot of people that
reach out to me because I work with that
one influencer out here that's like you
know she trains Danielle's dogs I need
her and they wait every two months for
me to come out so I started coming out
here six months ago
come out every two months and there's
always more and more dogs just raining
so it's cool yeah it's so fun so that's
how you monetize your business the
training and there's done anything above
and beyond that so that's more scalable
training the business local in San Diego
and then occasionally people and then a
personal branch just wrote a book more
like a business card mm-hmm yeah of
course
you guys sell published it yep yeah
that's why it's expensive yeah you just
want to be known as the best dog yeah we
started I started this business a year
ago year and a half ago
why because you knew you had a knack I
always wanted to be a veterinarian yeah
Hospital and you know with everything
medical there's politics so that just
like broke my heart you're like ha yeah
you're like nobody cares about the
animals I was devastated because ever
since I was 3 years old I wanted to be a
vet the same thing that every teacher
every politician everything that goes
into something bureaucratic yeah so it
was never like I'm like forget it is
just something that resorted back to
what am i passionate about fostering
dogs being involved in rescues and
connecting with dogs I just knew that I
always had this special connection with
dogs and I could communicate to owners
you know this dog is doing this because
this so I was giving advice to friends
among like rescues and soon I became
like the go-to train wreck so funny the
way you just described that's the same
way I feel about business I always know
what the other pieces are that create
the thing right which is how you thought
about right dogs peeing because you're
doing this on your food or the relation
it's so interesting I get it I get it
he's a business puzzle that other people
% yeah totally so from that just
everybody asking me advice I'm like I
can make a living off of this giving my
advice and I just use everything that
I've learned so what are you putting out
content now Instagram what what kind
like a vlog style how to like little
pieces of content pieces of content so a
training sessions like an hour long have
you thought about doing in a call-in
podcast show like askgaryvee yeah ask
the trainer I think you would kill that
like the amount of people that would
call you to a Google Voice number and me
like my dog and you again like I do with
business you're like look I'm not there
so I don't know what Snuffy's doing but
the three cliche things I see when a dog
is tearing the fence is you've got him
on a leash too much she's eating the
wrong kind of food do you have a second
dog like if you can the reason I'm
successful is because I can see the
pieces I know the 47 patterns that they
normally are I can do that the reason I
can still do vaynermedia and other
things is surely if I can get more
details then I can 100% get it done you
might not be able to answer everything
every time but you might be able to help
eight out of ten people I would highly
recommend doing a podcast highly and I
would highly recommend doing it a ask
new questions that's the whole show you
have to do nothing you have to have some
audience go on Instagram live put up
phone numbers pick the phone numbers I
mean you've seen askgaryvee I assume
it's not super hard you it would work I
would get you need to get the phone
numbers right so whether it's Facebook
live or Instagram live I don't know
where your audience is you need to be
able to like pick some phone calls
numbers because you don't have a switch
desk so you need to have a phone
speakerphone or however you do it I mean
this is my way there's probably smarter
or better ways but you need to just pick
phone numbers and be like hey Karen from
Kansas any what's your question cuz you
don't want them calling like you can't
like I don't know if you want or maybe
you do want a switchboard I don't
[ __ ] know but you know I don't how
you guys doing say there you go but you
know bottom line is you want to get a
show where you
and for 30 minutes 20 minutes you answer
three to five questions and I think most
knowledgeable professionals time ago
most knowledgeable professionals should
do an ask format show right now on
Facebook or in a podcast form or for
Google because Q&A
besides interviewing somebody Q&A is the
easiest way to create content instead of
creating it yourself yeah you know the
whole document versus create well maybe
you guys don't want to be reality TV
stars and document your whole day so if
you don't want to go that route you know
my whole thing is just start and what
holds everybody back is creation which
is why documenting over create became
such a big thing but not everybody wants
to put me on camera all the time so the
next version of document over create is
document Q&A create the Q&A is the
middle one the Q&A is the way for you to
produce unbelievable content and you'll
have to do anything you just have to
answer four questions which you know how
to do the biggest reason people aren't
successful is they don't actually know
the answers they're playing the part
there's a lot of dog trainers that are
trying to be celebrity dog trainers on
Instagram right now that don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about and the
same same ways physical trainers same
ways business gurus wine experts
sneakerheads there's a whole lot of
[ __ ] faking going on but if you
actually have the goods Q&A you know why
you can show your skills on the spot
you're not scared of anything
you know why all these [ __ ] don't do
QA they want to control the message they
don't have the [ __ ] answer
QA you're on the spot the reason I only
want to do Q&A is that's where I get to
show my strength yeah cool go
neither three sets I got a go